un día después del primer debate
electoral entre bolsonaro y Lula en el
que no hubo un claro ganador sale la
nueva encuesta del instituto ipec
encargada por el grupo globo Lula tiene
el 50% de la intención de votos y
bolsonaro el
43%, Eso quiere decir que Lula pierde un
punto con respecto a la última encuesta
del mismo instituto mientras que
bolsonaro se mantiene estable los votos
en blanco o nulo suman el 5% del total
Eso quiere decir que si miramos los
votos útiles Eso es en la cantidad total
menos los indecisos los votos nulos en
blanco bolsonaro tendría el
46%, y Lula el 54% o sea todavía está
por delante de su rival hay que recordar
que esta encuesta no refleja la
impresión de los ciudadanos tras este
primero debate porque se realizó antes
el fin de semana antes del debate y hay
que destacar que Brasil se caracteriza
por publicar una cantidad enorme de
encuestas y que la ley electoral permite
Incluso publicarlas el mismo día de las
elecciones